As me and river were leaving the farm to go to ballet,
um, this was by the driveway gate.
So while she's in ballet and I'm waiting for her to be done,
I thought I would unbox it with you.
This is a set of 12 glass storage containers.
We make about 90% of our food from scratch on the farm.
I'm not saying that we everything from scratch,
because that's just ridiculous.
But I wanna make our lifestyle as non toxic as possible.
So when storing the food that I spend so much time making,
it's really important that we have glass food containers.
Four years ago, I threw all of our plastic containers away.
So I only store food in either mixing bowls with foil
or a cloth over them, or I use, um,
glass containers like this.
But I saw this glass container set and I just had to have it.
Like, look at these. Cute.
They're all different sizes.
I really like how they have, like,
a fluted edge to them,
and there's different sizes perfectly sized for that.
Like, I have small things I make,
like small dairy products I make sometimes,
like sour cream.
I don't make a lot of that cause the kids don't eat a lot of it.
Many other SUVs. It's freaking me out.
It's like a competition. Who is the best SUV,
the newest SUV? Are you a black SUV mom,
or are you a white SUV mom?
And I Still use plastic lids with Mason jars
because the food doesn't actually touch the plastic.
Like the lid here, the food doesn't actually touch the lid.
So let's get the rest of them out.
They have good packaging, so the other ones are inside.
Go to all that time and effort to make your food from scratch.
Don't store in plastic.
Make sure you're storing your food in direct contact with glass.
I'm gonna be using these now in the kitchen
instead of using mixing bowls of rags at the top.
We don't have a lot of leftovers,
but I will be using these more for stuff that I'm making
and I wanna preserve. More for preserving food than storing food,
because we don't have many leftovers,
and we honestly feed our dogs most of the leftovers, um,
because I believe that dog
feeding human great food is better than eating dog kibble.
These are perfect for any kitchen.
If you're just starting out cooking from scratch,
or even doing it for years,
even if you don't cook from scratch,
and you want to store your leftovers that you spend time cooking,
then these are perfect for that.
To wash it safe, BPA free,
and lead free. If you're gonna buy any or use any food containers,
I highly, highly suggest that you use glass ones.